chaque candidat déchu au premier tour y
est allé ou pas de sa consigne de vote
mais qu'en était-il en 2002 et en 2017
quand l'extrême droite se qualifient au
second tour de la présidentielle
21 avril 2002 onde de choc jean marie le
pen et le front national déjoue les
pronostics et se retrouve au second tour
face à jacques chirac à l'époque
l'immense majorité des candidats
perdants au premier tour appelle à faire
barrage au fn le front national c'est
pour nous un courant qui représente
l'héritage de vichy d'olivier besancenot
candidat anti capitaliste alain madelin
candidats à droite ils sont plusieurs à
appeler au pro républicain pour noël
mamère candidat écologiste sa consigne
de vote elle est claire il n'y a aucune
hésitation pour dire qu'il faut appeler
à voter chirac le 5 mai idem pour
corinne lepage l'une des candidates
centriste j'appelle au rassemblement de
tous les hommes et femmes épris de
justice épris de liberté défenseur de la
république à faire barrage à jean marais
le les communistes et les socialistes
appellent aussi à faire barrage à
l'extrême droite de son côté arlette
laguiller du parti lutte ouvrière ne
change pas ses habitudes elle refuse de
donner une consigne de vote pour le
second tour nous voulons combattre le
pen mais il ne peut se combattre que sur
le plan social et par d'autres moyens
que ceux qu'ont proposé chirac ou jospin
seul bruno mégret autres candidats
d'extrême droite soutient jean marie le
pen au second tour d'un an plus tard en
2017 le fn est une nouvelle fois au
second tour d'une présidentielle avec
marine le pen comme candidate mais cette
fois difficile de parler de front
républicain de la part des candidats
déchus au premier tour seul le
républicain françois fillon et le
socialiste benoît hamon appelle
clairement à voter pour le candidat
allait re m emmanuel macron j'appelle
donc à battre le plus fortement et le
plus puissamment possible le front
national à battre l'extrême droite à
battre l'extrême droite en votant pour
emmanuel macron je voterai donc en
faveur d' emmanuel macron
et les autres votez macron s'abstenir
voter blanc pour le candidat npa
philippe poutou aucune consigne de vote
pareil pour jean luc mélenchon de la
france en soumises qui reste ambigu
chacun chacune d'entre vous
fait en conscience
quel est son devoir pour le centriste
jean lassalle ça sera un vote blanc et
comme en 2002 le front national ne
reçoit qu'un soutien j'annonce
officiellement que je soutiendrai marine
le pen en 2022 le souverainiste nicolas
dupont aignan a annoncé soutenir une
nouvelle fois marine le pen pour le
second tour elle est aussi rejoindre par
eric zemmour autres candidats l'extrême
droite mais la majorité des candidats
appelés à voter emmanuel macron comme le
communiste fabien roussel l'écologiste
yannick jadot ou encore la socialiste
anne hidalgo
[Musique]